I wanted my doctor to say that I should cut back at vitamin A because my liver enzymes
are going up.
I'm taking the ADK three times a day and he wants my vitamin D lower set 123 are these
numbers okay.
He also thinks green tea can be hard on the liver, but I don't want to cut back on the
TV go.
Thank you.
I would say that you could you're taking three a day at the vitamin ADK that's 15,000
I use a D. I'm not concerned with the A that's a good source A in the ADK so I'm not concerned
with the A in there, so I disagree with your doctor lightly, but and I'm not saying that
you need to decrease your D, but 123 is good, it's right where you're at, but maybe you
don't need.
And I said last week you could probably drop the two or one of those a day.
I do agree that green tea extract can be hard on your liver because 90% of green tea
extract sold in America is loaded with toxins, the TV goal is not.
So I would not cut back on the TV goal.
So it is that it's not going to be hard on your liver.